the first trains will run in 2026. in
just over a decade's time we'll have
Journeys from hearing crew people are
going to see these improvements soon in
this decade rather than having to wait
till the likes of 2040s to to see it
deliver
at over a decade of broken promises High
Speed 2 has been delayed yet again with
the government announcing that
affordability pressures mean more hold
ups and cutbacks that will impact mostly
on phase two from Birmingham through
Crewe to Manchester
for This Crew business finding out that
the town's High-Speed Rail connection
will be subject to a two-year delay
taking the completion date to 2036 has
come as a blow clearly it's
disappointing the local economy is is
being built on the back of hs2 coming to
crew obviously crew name twitch the
towns and villages in the surrounding
area are all looking for that boost to
the economy and any delay obviously
means that that's a delay for the local
economy and the infrastructure more
criticism from those who have long
campaigned to improve transport links
across the north the fact that we
haven't managed to build Northern
Powerhouse rail in hs2 will definitely
hold back our economic growth because
the poor productivity issues in the
north of England are directly correlated
to the poor transport that made me late
for this interview happens all the time
in the capital the central London Hub in
Houston will also take years longer than
planned it's to keep costs down on a
project whose budget has already
ballooned from 33 billion pounds to over
70 billion pounds
its end date now Beyond 2040 30 years
since it was first announced
and some conservative MPS are calling on
the government to cut their losses we
don't need to spend this money we could
improve the railways we've got with
better signaling with improvements that
gets more trains on the west coast
Mainline for example let's just say
sorry we made a mistake
save that money on a point of order Mr
Deputy speaker accused of burying the
news in a written statement the deputy
speaker agreed with labor that a
minister must come to the house to face
questions once the chair does not have
the power to bring ministers to the
dispatch box there has to be an
expectation that members will have the
earliest opportunity to question
ministers on this statement this teaser
week that could further derail what has
long been one of the UK's most divisive
transport projects Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster